Daniel: Hello and welcome.
It's March 17, 2023.
We're here in ActInf Livestream
Number 53.0.
Welcome to the active institute.
We're a participatory online institute
that is communicating, learning and
practicing applied active inference.
You can find us at the links on the
slide.
This is a recorded and archived live
stream, so please provide feedback so we
can improve our work.
All backgrounds and perspectives are
welcome.
We'll be following video etiquette for
live streams, head over active
inference.org to learn more about the
institute and getting involved with
learning groups and projects.
We're here in Acdam stream number 53.0,
and our goal is to learn and discuss a
pair of papers.
The first paper is Snakes and Ladders in
Paleoanthropology from Cognitive Surprise
to Skillfulness a Million Years Ago by
Hector Manrique, Carl Friston and Michael
Walker.
The article was posted to Sci Archive in
2022 and the second paper is to copy or
not to copy, that is the question from
Chimpanzees to the foundation of Human
Technological Culture.
This paper is with Menrique and Walker as
authors.
Fristenless it was also uploaded to Psy
Archive.
And recently, as we have been delighted
to discover, the paper has been accepted
in Physics of Life reviews.
However, the quotes that we're drawing
from and reading from today are drawn
from the Psy Archive version.
Just so people know and like all the
videos, we're here to make an
introduction for some of the dean and the
materials.
It's not a review or a final word.
In this 53.0 video, we're going to
introduce ourselves, say hello, and then
we are going to call it like we see it
with the aims and claims abstract roadmap
keywords.
And there are no figures or formalisms in
these papers, but I think we'll have
enough bounded surprise to navigate
nonetheless.
So let us begin with introductions and
then we'll head into big questions.
So. Dean.
Dean: Thanks, Danny.
I'm Dean.
I'm here in Calgary.
I'm not going to do much around the warm
up question piece because I've got a big
question coming up, so I'll pass it over
to you.
Daniel: I'm Daniel, I'm in California and
agreed.
Please lead in with your big questions.
Dean: Well, I'm going to start by just
sort of highlighting the big questions
that the authors have, if that's okay.
I'll just read them out.
So for the Snakes and Ladder paper, there
were a number of questions that sort of
enabled the authors to go forward with
their ideas.
Two questions arise.
First, what is it that could provoke
cognitive awareness as to the possibility
of fashioning stone hand axes in relation
to the affordances of raw materials and
potential advantages for minimizing
bioenergetic effort?
Secondly, what does this say about the
irregular appearance of this regular
technique in the Pleistocene spatial
temporal record?
Also, how was remembered awareness
retrieved from personal, short and long
term memory transmitted as knowledge to
others in whose memories it could become
embedded with a degree of fidelity
sufficient to enable intergenerational or
intercommunal diffusion?
How far was observational learning
involved?
Do you want me to read the CRNC, or do
you want to do that yourself?
Daniel: All right, I'll read the
questions from the authors in Copy or not
to Copy.
They wrote, Why do chimpanzees not live
in a complex technological world?
Why does innovation fail to translate
into technological cumulative
complexity?
Does it owe to a limited capacity to copy
with fidelity?
What is the implication for innovations?
What ingredients must be present from a
free energy principle standpoint in
innovators minds brains and in observers
mind slash brains for innovation to take
root in a community and be transmitted
between generations?
Dean: Yeah, great questions.
Now, how do we want well, we know how we
want to do this, but one of the things
before we get too far along is we, as
hosts today, really want to honor the
fact that a lot of time has been spent
making sure that the ideas that the
authors want to bring into the public
domain are very clear and that we don't
read a whole bunch into it.
Now, we're not going to speculate.
We're not going to go off on any kind of
tangent here.
We're going to try to focus strictly on
the arguments that they are putting
forward, because they're putting forward
some pretty strong and I think, well
evidenced arguments.
So although there's lots of questions
being asked, they're also trying to
provide a few very defendable answers.
Daniel: Absolutely.
That is to prelude the questions that we,
Dean and I and Ali are asking.
And then we're going to dive largely into
verbatim quotations from the texts, and
we'll have a dessert session where we
bring up some future topics and ideas.
What big question brought you into this?
Dean: 53 dean okay, so apologies.
There's going to be a lot of reading
today, so if you don't like my voice,
you're going to just read this and hit
the pause button.
But anyway, the attention topical
transition is paper one to paper two.
And we're not really spending a lot of
time right now saying which came first
because we think of them as a pair.
The shift between snakes and ladders
model of evolution and learning
comparisons across species with special
attention given to innovation as copying
ability.
Both papers there is much to say and
discuss around learning as an uptake
exercise.
If as reviewers, people reading these
papers, we were to take an active and
then in between that and inference
anthropologist, archaeologist,
comparative psychologist approach to
combining these manuscripts.
And then I singled out many examples of
where the authors speak expressively
around combining combinatorial, and you
can read that on your own.
If we were to look at combinations, what
might we learn when bicameral, for
example, two eyes and bi temporal meaning
holding up then and now strategies as
analysis are approximated with active and
inference as parentheses tool uptake, for
example, telescopes and microscope
usage.
After before or concurrent with
compounding strategy uptake.
So that's my big question.
And I think we're probably not going to
get close to an answer until the dot
two.
That's why it's a big question because I
think it's going to be able to span a
little bit of a window here.
Daniel: Great.
And I wrote a shorter question.
Apart from other applications, for
example, in research and development or
in other fields or looking towards the
future, how does the free energy
principle and active inference serve as a
historical framework or approach?
So whether we lean towards Aristotelian
Causation Philosophies or Tinbergen's
approach to ethology behavioral analysis,
how does a historical explanatory power
fit in amongst the wise, the plurality of
wise in our investigations?
And Ali, who is joining for some
discussions, proposed the question how
can self organized systems use copy
discard functions to store information?
A little bit of an externalization from
our category theory developments that I'm
sure will arise later.
So you go for the top, I'll go for the
bottom.
Dean: Okay.
So just before I start, I want to really
emphasize the fact that the authors I
think to really comprehend what the
authors are trying to put forward as an
idea here, you have to really spend some
time thinking through the aims of the
papers and the claims.
We placed a heavy emphasis.
We're going to give a lot more time over
to that.
It's going to seem like we're going to
give a lot of time over to the keys
because having talked to the authors
prior to coming on and doing this live
stream set, they use those terms of the
key and the key to unlocking some of
these ideas that have been held for a
long time.
So apologies again if it seems like we're
text heavy or dialogue heavy.
But in order to really appreciate what's
going on, you have to kind of get it out
there.
So for the Snakes and Labs paper, provide
a hypothesis, a paradigmatic account
around how variational free energy is
both individual ontogenetic and
collective.
Phylogenetic modeling could have played a
part in what could now be described as a
methodological fep paradigm or relating
biological and technological behavior in
homo, snakes and ladders in this context
pertains to appearances and
disappearances of Paleolithic skills in
the early and middle Pleistocene record.
Our proposal invokes a methodological
paradigm grounded in existential
principles that underpin the evolution of
living organisms.
It is that some, at least of the
irregular, regularities and regular
irregularities of phenomena attributable
to homo in the Pleistocene record reflect
the kinds of plausibility anomalous
behavior outcomes that doubtless occurred
often in a stakes and ladder model of
evolution in early members of Ardenus,
regardless of their skeletal
paleospecific taxonomy.
Daniel: Awesome.
I'll read the bottom and then feel free
to explain the side by side visually.
They wrote into copy or not to copy.
An aim is to introduce the notion that
chimpanzees and other great apes show
considerable limitations in their
ambiguity or zone of bounded surprisal to
overcome cognitive surprisal induced by
innovative or unorthodox behavior, which
is rarely is copied precisely or
accurately.
So things that can be innovated in a
moment but do not have the ability to be
recognized and carried forward.
And they discussed the circumstances
under which Pleistocene homo underwent
remarkable evolutionary adaptation of
neurobiological propensities.
Cerebral aspects are discussed.
That it is proposed here were fundamental
for faithful copying, which underpins
social transmission of technology's,
cumulative culture and culture.
Dean: So I think what we're going to be
doing is holding up two things at once.
The two things are copying as repetition
and copying as origination, if there is
such a word.
But essentially of these images here,
there are copies that were simply cut and
pasted so they were repeated.
And then there was one representation
between those two that's an origination.
It didn't exist to be copied, but now it
can be.
So now what we're going to be doing is
looking at, okay, so how does maybe all
of that play out when we're observing the
world around us, when we're taking things
in and trying to reduce our surprise?
How many things are we being deep faked
on?
How many things are action action
oriented representation therefore
manageable as two very different places
of understanding or appreciation, maybe?
Daniel: Great.
All right.
I'll go for the first of the sections and
then feel free to comment on them or to
pick up on the second sections.
So in snakes and Ladders, they wrote,
cognitive surprises favoring anomalous
behavioral propensities to sporadic
expression, can explain snakes and
ladders appearances and disappearances of
paleolithic skills in the early and
middle Pleistocene.
Record some behavioral outcomes
attributable plausibly to individual
members of homo unable to maintain
orthodox behavior responses when faced
with cognitive surprises, which is
surprisal in the Bayesian terminology.
Such individuals may show a particular
neurobiological propensity for exploring
unorthodox possibilities.
The propensity has evolved further in
humans than in great apes, which, unlike
even our very young children, our larvae
seem unable to envisage how things might
be as well as how they actually are,
whereas by coupling recall of past
experience with prospective memory,
humans are capable of blending reality
among different potential spheres.
Dean: Statistical considerations of
classical population genetics are
incommensurate with notions that
Darwinian fitness and Pleistocene homo
increased imperceptibly through gradual
dual inheritance.
Coevolution inherited changes proceeded
in well nigh invariant lockstep with
heritability of active behavioral and
technological changes.
Although ontogenetic autopoiesis may
involve action perception cycles, a
phylogenetic consequence could include
unawareness by companions that those
exceptions might allow new cooperative
opportunities for minimizing the group's
variation of free energy by performing
unaccustomed behavior to attain dubious
benefit.
Though foresight of fluent communication
innovations often must have disappeared
unremarket, seen as useless and their
creator's prowess as misplaced energy and
wasting time needed for satisfying the
group's existentially implacable,
energetics prepotent, routine behavior,
and prosocial early homo plausibly
resulted in failure to become aware of
the potential of idiosyncratic active
outcomes.
Here a prosaic approach merely inverts
that narrative approach to interpreting
the deep past, which draws for its
inspiration on humane and social
studies.
The inversion subordinates the narrative
approach to critical scrutiny, such that
the narrative approach no longer seems to
be the most appropriate or most
parsimonious interpretation available.
Now, again, what we're doing is trying to
avoid the situation where we're cherry
picking.
So if you want to pause and read what's
been written in context, please feel free
to do that.
But we just want to make sure that we
touch on the highest peaks in this
range.
Daniel: Yes, the full papers are out
there.
We're linearizing and curating in this
zero, which has been an incredible
experience and that has helped us grasp
some of these points, hopefully, so we
can take them further.
And I'll read the quote and then you can
go into the red zone.
Dean: Yeah, go for it.
Daniel: In Snakes and Ladders, they wrote
the argument proposed here about a
neurobiological propensity to an
individual enactment in modifying stone,
considered from the standpoint of the
free energy principle, is not concerned
with a null hypothesis of innate latent
spontaneity.
Instead, it is directed towards
interpreting irregular regularities and
regular irregularities in the Pleistocene
snakes and ladders.
Record of appearances and disappearances
of Bflcts, which we're going to get to
tools.
Given presence of BF lCTs in widely
differing biotopes.
Which likely led to differential
behavioral evolution of appropriate
subsistence strategies and diets.
There is widespread comparability of the
principal morphological attributes of BF
lCTs of diverse Petrology at sites with
contrasting paleo environments and
different spatiotemporal contexts or
paleoanthropological taxa.
This renders unlikely any notion of a
straightforward mendelian genetic basis
favoring BF Lct outcomes by natural
selection for a specific behavior
adaptation.
The circumstantial evidence seems to
apply the adaptive evolution of human
neurobiology propensities that support
prospective memory in tool making,
together with short term working memory,
including haptic working memory, long
term working memory, and long term
procedural memory and episodic memory of
past matters and things.
Dean: So I'm doing a tease here, because
on the previous slide, I starred one of
the claims and then the last claim on
this slide here, my note is essentially,
I'm just going to read the part that
doesn't again, have me speculating memory
broken into types, as you can see here.
Working memory, long term, procedural, et
cetera.
And now being applied instrumentally.
Did all the memory types at some
threshold of uptake afford a parallel
processing of time, given time's
potential variance over the simpler
sequential sense of change as the starter
pack priority today?
When I say starter pack priority today,
how much about what we do today is being
projected or overfit onto the deep past?
This is a question that Michael's
presentation in the 53 one is going to
have much to say.
Also the last claim of the copy or not to
copy.
So a bit of a teaser.
You're going to want to show up for 53
one, because I think Michael's
presentation is going to really open up a
lot of eyes.
Daniel: Awesome.
Into to copy or not to copy, we go to
their claims.
So just to read some of the first parts,
what is the implication for innovations?
A sinaquanon for one to spread.
So something that must happen to spread
is following its conception by one mind,
namely the hmm hierarchically,
mechanistic mind of the protagonist
brain.
It must then be apprehended by another
mind, namely the hmm of an observer's
brain.
And we're going to come back to that on
the roadmap.
Here, innovations represent an anomaly,
and innovators are unorthodox actors or
protagonists.
Their policy selection is in a sense,
faulty, in the sense that their ensuing
behavioral outcomes are in market
contrast to those of their fellow actors
or agents who deploy orthodox responses
that reduce discrepancies between
predictions and sensation.
Thus, innovators fail to fulfill their
predictions.
If innovations be regarded as behavior
outputs, theirs are then responses that
fall outside the repertoire typical of
their community, and hence ceterais
paribus all of the things equal increase
the prediction error, e.
G the level of cognitive surprisal in
their exchanges with the surrounding eco
niche.
Dean: Predicted consequences of any
observed innovative behavior will be too
imprecise for the cons specific to make
sense of that novel or unorthodox
behavior.
When sense cannot be made, copying cannot
take place.
Very clear.
When brains cope with high levels of
cognitive surprisals, a plausible answer
is that it is when the holding capacity
of working memory increases from two to
three.
Working memory in this setting
corresponds to the temporal depth of
generative models that generate or
predict the consequences of successive
actions.
This transition increases temporal
horizon, which amplifies cognitive
versatility and one of my favorite
things, recursive thinking.
A working memory or detemporal model able
to entertain diverse novel Bayesian
beliefs is more likely able to recognize
and remember innovative behaviors.
And it's easier for chimpanzees to
perform complex action that involve
considerable motor demands than it is for
them to reproduce actions that are simple
and undemanding with regard to motor
dexterity and yet unorthodox with regard
to their habitual behavioral repertoire.
Daniel: Great.
I'll just joke and meme internally as we
carry forward.
Yeah, go for the top half here.
Dean: All right, I'll do the first
three.
When considering early Pleistocene
behavior, we need not assume memories
were less complex psycho cognitively than
are ours.
It is prosaically sufficient to infer
that they were simply less frequent owing
to earlier consolidation of cerebral
networks in Homo erectus's smaller
brain.
And we're going to get into something
called the zone of bounded surprisal
here.
And after the ZVS restricted them,
observations by early Homo erectus were
translated often into activity
intermediate between I love that
emulation and imitation owing to limited
foresight.
That or there zbs limited their ambiguity
to join up the mental steps involved in
planning and to infer counterfactual
possibilities.
The focus of the Zbs is on the observers
and their ability to make sense of an
observed innovation.
The ZPs allows any potentially novel or
unorthodox behavior to be copied provided
that the ranges or the levels of surprise
provoked in observers are tolerated or
manageable by.
Daniel: There'S bilateral neuronal
activation in some brain regions.
When some tools are being fashioned,
activation is bilateral because
fashioning stone requires precise and
accurate monitoring by right hemisphere
neurons of the left hand holding the
future artifact as well as the action
planning.
It performed by the right hand holding a
hammerstone which are monitored by left
hemisphere neurons.
Together they coordinate continuously
changing sensory motor representations
with appropriately changing hand
movements undertaken in an organized
forward sequence of perception action
with feedback.
Entertaining multiple and varied
predictions in the Bayesian framework
represented as probability densities in
alternate models generated about reality
enables the narrowing of cognitive gaps
or lessening of cognitive dissonance or
surprisal when conspecifics are seen to
carry out unusual or unorthodox behaviors
that paves the way for horizontal and
vertical transmission.
The working memory capacity of
chimpanzees seems to be below that
tipping point at which multiple mental
spheres or possibilities can be
entertained simultaneously for pitting
against an observed novel behavior while
keeping cognitive surprisal within a
tolerable range unsurprisingly.
No copying occurs when innovations
observed deviate markedly from usual
chimpanzee behavior.
Dean: Can I just throw something in
here?
Now, at this point we'll step back and
think about this as a live stream.
We are trying to avoid a tipping point by
placing a heavy weighting on the aims and
claims relative to most of the live
streams that we've done in the past.
This is a big build up, but think of this
as your classic barbell analogy.
We've just tipped one plate on the bar.
Now we're going to look at the bar and
then we're going to look at the other
plates on the other side of this.
When we get to the keys.
Daniel: You can go for the first
abstract.
I'll do a second.
Dean: You got it.
Okay.
A scientific paradigmatic account
suffices to interpret behavior evolution
in early homocognitive surprises favoring
anomalous behavioral propensities to
sporadic expression can explain stakes
and ladders appearances and
disappearances of paleolithic skills in
the early and middle class scene record.
The account applies to the principle of
stationary action which underpins the
free energy principle to self organizing
systems at an evolutionary timescale.
Unusual personal attainments, often
explained by invoking progressive ascent
of evolutionary phylogenetic ladders of
cognitive and technical abilities could
be disregarded in a hominid community
that failed to imagine or articulate
possible advantages for its
survivability.
Such failure, as well as diverse
fortuitous demographic accidents could
erase from collective memory the
recollection of exceptional individual
conduct which disappeared down a snake,
so to speak, of the human evolutionary
puzzle.
The puzzle discomforts
paleoanthropologists.
The gloves are on.
Some explain it away with the self
justifying assertion that separate paleo
species of Homo differentially possessed
cognitive abilities that allegedly
underlay the differential presence or
absence in the Pleistocene archaeological
record of traces of particular behavioral
outcomes or skills.
An alternative methodological perspective
grounded in the fundamental relationships
between organisms and their environments
affords parsimonious prosaic deflationary
account for appearances and
disappearances of behavior, outcomes, and
skills.
Thus the title snakes and Ladders great.
Daniel: And the Abstract of Copy or not
to Copy.
A prerequisite for copying innovative
behavior is the capacity of observers
brains, regarded as hierarchically
mechanistic minds, to overcome cognitive
surprisal by maximizing the evidence for
their internal models via active
inference.
Unlike modern humans, chimpanzees and
other great apes show considerable
limitations in their ability or zone of
bounded surprisal to overcome cognitive
surprisal induced by innovative or
unorthodox behavior, which rarely is
copied precisely or accurately, most can
copy adequately what is within their
phenotypically habitual behavioral
repertoire in which technology plays a
scant part.
Widespread intra and intergenerational
social transmission of complex
technological innovations is not a
hallmark of great ape taxa over 3 million
years ago.
Precursors of the genus Homo made stone
artifacts and stone flaking was likely
habitual before 2 million years ago.
After this time, early Homo erectus left
traces of technological innovations,
though faithful copying of these and
their intra and intergenerational social
transmission were rare before a million
years ago.
This likely ode to a cerebral
infrastructure of interconnected neuronal
networks that bounds the expressivity of
internal world models entailed by their
functional architecture.
Brains were smaller in size than ours,
and cerebral neuronal networks ceased to
develop when early Homo erectus attained
full adult maturity by the mid teen
years, whereas their development
continues until our mid 20s.
Nowadays, Pleistocene Homo underwent
remarkable evolutionary adaptation of
neurobiological propensities.
Cerebral aspects are discussed.
That it is proposed here were fundamental
for faithful copying, which underpins
social transmission of technologies,
cumulative learning and culture.
Great.
One of the most amazing.
Roadmap became road.
Rail became train station clearinghouse
slides.
So what is happening?
Dean: I think the great gift that the
authors have provided Daniel and I here
is the opportunity, because this work is
talking about sequential time.
And when on that timeline did things
happen?
Which came first or why did something
that we thought came after?
Suddenly we find new evidence that maybe
it didn't come after.
Maybe it was co occurring.
And so what I wanted to do in this
particular slide was talk about things
like timelines and timetables around the
idea of a learning destination,
assumptions that learning does have some
sense of convergence.
So my question was, well, what if all
roads, be they rail or paved, lead to an
active Rome or Romeference?
Like, what is this journey that we're
on?
What is this interstate that we exist
within?
And why do we always assume that what
we're looking at is the ties between the
rails, instead of making sure that when
we're talking about a tipping point,
we're talking about the fact that the
entire underlying structure can hold up?
The vehicle that Daniel and I are
basically sitting on right now and moving
forward with back and forth?
So the timelines and timetables to
learning destinations are not uptakes.
Someone else's formatting is not your
outing of a figure.
Okay, so I've never been on an official
dig site, but I have come across dinosaur
bones being in Alberta.
And so you stumble across these things
and whoa, what's that right.
In an otherwise field of clay, how much
can we schedule and how much is dependent
on the sophistication of our hierarchical
model?
And again, I've practiced this tutrenes,
Allendo and Las plateaformas unuenue with
apologies to Hector.
Where are we departing?
All we know is that platforms one and
nine let's go.
Vamos.
Daniel: All aboard.
But great visualization.
The papers do have sections.
However, without figures or formalisms,
we were able to and drawing on the unique
subject matter and contributions, able to
also even reconsider the linearity and
the structure of the stream.
The keywords are displayed on the slide
just to quickly read through them.
In Snakes and Ladders free energy
principle fep paleolithic enactment
irregular regularities and regular
irregularities, haptic working memory
tasks prospective episodic and procedural
memory phylogenetic and ontogenetic
timescales favoring anomalous behavioral
propensities to sporadic expression.
The principle of stationary action
applied to self organizing systems at an
evolutionary timescale and in copy or not
to Copy chimpanzees cumulative culture
free Energy principle generative model,
homo erectus, innovation, observer, stone
tools, technology and the zones of
bounded surprisal.
What can you add about the published
priors?
Dean: Well, I just think it's interesting
because we've always used this image of
the sort of the infinite and antherence
ref which I've always really liked
because I just momentarily lost the
strange loop piece.
What is that mobius?
Is it a mobius?
Daniel: Right, a mobius stripped, also
developed by here Mcscher and Doug
Hofstadter into the strange loop
concept.
Dean: Right.
So all I wanted to do is add the fact
that maybe there is these branch lines.
And when we're talking about published
priors, I know that in the chronological
time they came first, but if we were now
to go to them post having read these
papers, what would that reveal?
Right?
Like is a branch less important than the
trunk?
I guess, I don't know.
Without a trunk there are no branches,
but without branches there's no
totality.
So that's what I was kind of laying out
there.
Daniel: Also, with respect to the
literature, it's a canonical example of
cumulative culture.
It's all at once and the timing of which
through Kronos publications were added in
is by no means the Kronos or the Cairos
of the learner or the researcher.
So going from just the past and the
present, two min two of the literature to
the past, present and future.
Three with literature expands into the
key points with another disclaimer for
your health.
Dean: There are no cole's notes version
that will both make sense and do
justice.
The analysis research arguments is laid
out in these papers.
We begin with keys and then start a
process of unlocking.
All right, so how do you want to do this,
Daniel?
Do you want to split each one of the
slides or do you want to just swap
slides?
I'll do one.
You do one?
Daniel: Yes.
You go for this slide?
You go for even slides?
I'll do odd slides.
Dean: Okay.
All right, so this is all the keys.
There are 17 of them from the Snakes and
ladder paper.
Again, I really strongly recommend you
have a read of this.
It's a fantastic paper, but if you want
the one and a half times speed version of
hearing it, this is what it sounds like.
Evidence of early and middle clustened
behavior is distributed in
disconcertingly uneven ways between
2,200,000 years ago.
Our proposal is that some, at least of
the irregular, regularities and regular
irregularities of phenomenal attributable
to homo in the Pleistocene record reflect
the kinds of plausibly anomalous behavior
outcomes that doubtless occurred often in
a sacred ladders model of evolution in
early members of our genus.
Regardless of their skeletal
Paleospecific taxonomy, increasingly
complex extractive and concomitant or
consequent procedures appear in several
parts of the world at various times
towards the end of the Lake Pleistocene.
Some seem to have arisen separately and
independently in a snakes and ladders
fashion and with different outcomes at
different places and times.
Self evidencing underwrites much of the
following arguments, however, there is an
important nuance.
Certain creatures may have evolved deep
generative models with the ability to
predict the consequences of their
actions.
This kind of creature now has the
capacity to entertain counterfactual
futures under different actions.
This is a key aspect of active inference
under the fep.
Namely, actions and plans are selected on
the basis of minimizing expected free
energy under that plan.
In terms of Bayesian mechanics, evolution
and natural selection can be regarded as
natural Bayesian model selection, which
is also known as structured learning in
the cognitive sciences.
Evolution thus develops imperceptibly and
intermittently.
And the fep concept is biologically and
especially neurobiologically relevant
both at ontogenetic levels of cellular
dynamics, neural circuitry and behavior,
and at phylogenetic levels of populations
evolved through natural selection of
biological adaptations and adaptability.
Just before we move on because there's a
bunch of other keys here.
I hope it makes sense that not only are
we setting the bars up or the plates up
on either end of the bar, if we're
talking about a tipping point, we as the
agent who are going to now bring that bar
down to our chest and then reextend
ourselves.
We don't want the tipping point to be the
bar comes down and then squishes us.
So us setting this up, there's not a
tipping point as a threshold is met and
over the whole thing goes.
The tipping point is here.
Is there some agent.
That's actually capable of we're talking
directly about that.
Daniel: Continuing with snakes and
ladders doubtless tried and trusted
routines predominated, and whoever
performed them with daily efficiency was
trusted by the group, whereas eccentric
or idiosyncratic conduct was treated with
indifference and not retained in
collective memory or lore.
prepotent routine behavior plausibly
resulted in failure to become aware of
potentially idiosyncratic, inactive
outcomes.
There is a difference between a
spatiotemporal snakes and ladders picture
of disappearances of tiny huntergatherer
bands and appearances of others, and the
snakes and ladders model of individual
idiosyncratic or unorthodox activity.
Heterogeneous composition renders the
former picture inappropriate for making
predictions, whereas the latter model
individual idiosyncratic or unorthodox
activity by focusing on the information,
theoretic, and energetic constraints on
biological neurobiological and
psychosocial evolution allows for the
consideration of whether, by doing so, it
may offer a reasonable interpretation of
the material record.
In particular, the uneven distribution of
stone hand axes and evidence of
paleolithic combustion between 2,200,000
years ago.
The marginal relevance of stone about 3
million years ago for the existential
biological imperative of maintaining
homeostatic integrity and consequent
reproductive success and survival of
inarticulate Hominina plausibly led
stones to be regarded as
quintessentially, predictable, and
unsurprising, and crucially, lacking
epistemic affordances implicit in tool
use.
Nevertheless, an individual could
entertain more expressive I.
E.
Deeper generative models and respond to
exploratory epistemic and exploitative
pragmatic value.
She might discover novel ways of
attaining predictable or unsurprising
outcomes through her behavior, and its
outcome may well have been disregarded by
her companions.
All the same, such idiosyncratic behavior
may trump prevailing expectations that
normally are unsurprising and therefore
favor minimization of variational.
Free energy in line with the free energy
principle, it is unclear by what
mechanism transmission of any conjectural
package could have been sustained over
the spatiotemporal dimensions involved,
and so, with respect to some kinds of
tool usage, it is imprudent to infer that
they reflect an unbroken tradition of
manual behavior handed down from
generation to generation.
If a generation lasts 25 years on
average, then 200,000 years imply 8000
generations, which presents a major
challenge for the culture history
approach to interpretation.
Dean: In late middle Pleistocene, Bflcts
were made by precursors of Hsapns in
Africa and neanderthals in Europe,
probably both used in the similar ways.
Nevertheless, the uneven spatial temporal
distribution of Bflcts is undeniable.
Cognitive and manual designs and
strategies for responses in common to
underlying neurobiological propensities
shared by the early middle Pleistocene.
Nappers and nappers are people that
actually form and shape these tools.
Sporadic local enactment by H.
Heidelberg.
Heidelbergnis could well have been
responsible for puzzling exceptional
finds of what at first sight looked like
impossibly early instances of
stoneworking techniques that flowered
only much later on, showing that hand
axes could be napped with care and
attention.
In Europe before the middle of the middle
Pleistocene, thereby disproving a
commonly held viewed to the contrary the
alternative ways of modifying stones that
appeared after two maimly on the one hand
to make lcts that's one sided and in
particular BF Lcts, and on the other, to
remove usable flakes from cores that also
may have undergone some modifications,
sometimes sort of facilitate the
removal.
Implies that H.
Erectus could carry out two different
irreversible chains of the manipulative
reduction of stone, implying a capacity
for haptic and short term working
memory.
Long term memory and prospective memory
respect beyond that of earlier homina or
extant pannons artifact diversity.
Implies that at times, H.
Erectus could recognize not only the
irreversibility of their respective
change of sequential manual reduction of
stone, but also their correspondence to
distinct morphological sets, which at
least is comparable to second order
cognition.
That's understood implicitly by preverbal
toddlers nowadays.
Well studied regional differences in the
development of gray matter, which may be
prolonged in temporal cortex, perhaps
related to its role in integrating
memory, object recognition and
audiovisual inputs.
From the perspective of the free energy
principle, these differences testify to
structural priors that inherit from
epigenetics and contextualize experience
dependent learning and planning as
inference at a somatic time scale.
Daniel: Great.
And continuing with Snakes and Ladders
also just to get it set as well, the BF
Lct is bifacially flaked large cutting
tools.
It's a type of tool.
The circumstantial evidence seems to
imply the adaptive evolution of human
neurobiological propensities that support
prospective memory and tool making
together with short term working memory,
including haptic working memory, long
term working memory, and long term
procedural memory and episodic memory of
past matters and things.
These propensities were and are
phylogenetic outcomes of existential
ontogenetic programs adapted through
natural selection for satisfying the
bioenergetic requirements of organisms.
However, teaching and learning stone
napping skills are very different from a
communicatively challenged H.
Erectus individual spontaneous enactment
resulting in a disregarded Bflct outcome
of iterative inactive haptic lithic
manipulations.
Regardless of any neurobiologically
evolved cognitive neuronal propensity for
such enactments, it's a huge claim.
Getting and fashioning stone for
subsequent use suggests awareness of
potential, albeit delayed, advantages for
lessening the efforts needed to acquire
bioenergetic resources.
Such behavior draws on short term and
long term working memory, episodic and
procedural memory, and prospective
memory, or forethought to a degree well
beyond the capacity of living anthropoid
apes.
Those are all the keys for Snakes and
Ladders.
There's a strong, relentless, even focus
on the moment of tool production, the
cognitive and extended cognitive
phenomena associated with the performance
of that act.
Specifically with regard to hominids and
with a focus on the Bflct bifacially
flaked large cutting tool of which the
authors have extensive field expertise
seeing in sichu.
So Snakes and Ladders uses this fun board
game metaphor or reference to explain the
sudden appearance and disappearance not
by appeal to a cultural continuity
mechanism tradition, but rather the
instantaneous, a gentle zone of bounded
surprise and action.
Dean: Now, just before we get into copy
or not to copy, what I think is what
we're trying to do here is hold up the
fact that we believe that these although
each each paper has been discretized to a
particular topic.
The continuity between the papers is what
we'd really like to emphasize here
because there are such strong strands
where basically the shores are within
such easy sight of one another that it's
very nice to be able to kind of float
back and forth.
We're going to now focus on the copy or
not to copy piece of this, but to say
that there isn't a way of being able to
look at this as a continuity.
I think we're trying to disrupt that
right now.
So try to hold on as much of the snakes
and ladder key points as you can as we
morph into this second perspective.
It's perspective Swapping 101.
Doesn't mean we're losing the details of
either.
Want me to start?
Oh, yeah, I'm on.
Evens you told me I had to do that.
Okay.
Social learning theories about how
information spreads do not explain how a
seed of information is planted in each
individual brain.
So we're back to the brain based stuff.
A useful lens is the free energy
principle, which underpins a generative
hierarchically mechanistic mind or hmm
surprising or uncharacteristic sensory
and physical states are precluded via a
minimization of variation of free
energy.
Interactions involve predictive
processing and consequent perception
action responses, active inference, yay
actively seeking predictive sensory
exchanges with the world that minimize
surprise or variation of free energy.
Fundamental involvement of learning minds
is precisely the minds I e.
The brains that are concerned in a
mechanistic approach, seeking to
ascertain the minimum requirements back
to that threshold thing for an innovation
to nest, as it were, in one individual's
brain before it can do so in another's.
Innovation and innovator are treated
throughout in the context of habitual,
phenotypical behavior of a species from
the perspective of a conspecific observer
who witnesses novel or unorthodox
behavior or its outcome, usually through,
but not necessarily those that owe.
To activity performed by a cons specific,
but which, at the time of the
observation, have not been adopted by
other conspecifics in the group and
therefore have not undergone social
transmission.
In many respects, the words are
synonymous with invention and inventor,
though these often connote post hoc
recognition, the imperative to maximize
the expected information, curious
behavior responding to epistemic
affordance resolves uncertainty and
thereby reduces the long term average of
prediction errors in the future.
However, this kind of innovative behavior
is risky owing to its deviation from
those phenotypical responses that
selection is favored in a specific
ecological niche.
Innovation, when viewed from Charles
Darwin's vantage point of evolution by
natural selection, may be a far from
advantageous.
Trait deviations can have untoward
consequences that even may threaten an
innovator's very survival before
reproductive age can be reached.
Oh, the risk reward.
Daniel: Prehawk post hoc and that fine
line that bridges the two.
Continuing with copy or not to copy, they
write and also I will add Dean has
excellently visually differentiated in
these slides.
Innovative behavior can be regarded as a
latent variable a plausible policy whose
posterior probability must be inferred
from a set of observations.
The family of probability densities
entertained by an individual is
restricted to the system's prior Bayesian
beliefs.
It can be the case that a conspecific's
innovative behavior will not fall neatly
into one of these prior conceptions of a
behavioral policy.
This means, by definition that innovative
behavior is both unlikely to be evinced
in any given phenotype and crucially
difficult to recognize when observed by
another.
Was true for modern art was true for the
large tools.
Small deviations by innovators may be
accommodated by observers who can take
discrepancies into account by making
minor adjustments.
An innovator's behavior, should it
diverge markedly from the repertoire of
plausible policies used by an observer to
predict another's behavior may be beyond
the capacity of the latter's generative
model.
A prerequisite of registering and
encoding surprising sites may well be an
ability to modify the generative model in
order to accommodate sensory evidence
that fails to meet top down predictions.
Brains might balance top down
expectations against bottom up sensory
evidence.
The ability to do that dynamically and to
conduct complex computations suggestive
of high attentional executive control
implies sensitivity to both previous
experience and the current context.
Perhaps the overriding of top down
predictions implies that those complex
attentional and strategic components of
working memory that distinguish humans
from chimpanzees plausibly familiarity by
conspecific observers with the actions
demonstrated in an experiment kept their
surprise associated with the demonstrated
actions within a manageable range.
And this in turn prompted copying.
And it's easier for chimpanzees to
perform complex actions that are
unorthodox sorry, chimpanzees.
It's easier for chimpanzees to perform
complex actions that involve considerable
motor demands than it is for them to
reproduce actions that are unorthodox.
With regard to their habitual behavior
repertoire, brains must shoulder an
additional energetic cost whenever novel
associative behavior responses are
introduced that may override those
already present.
The acceptability of reproducing a novel
artifact may owe at least as much to the
ways in which broadly similar copies
might be used with predictably accurate
outcomes.
Again, big serious disciplinary claims
also with broad transdisciplinary and
application consequences.
Dean: By focusing attention less on the
creative process of an innovation more on
the observers of it this acceptance of
the outcome underpins its intra and
intergenerational transmission.
Questions raise their head about just
what materialistic phenomena are
implicated as opposed to psychocognitive
and social cognitive notions about mental
developments during human evolution and
how and when the impinge on the hmm of
our neogene hominid precursors such that
only in places seen Homo was faithful
copying become widespread and give rise
to technological cumulative complexity.
It's obligatory, therefore, to pay
attention both to fundamental principles
of biological science with particular
reference to Neurobiology and to the
evolution of binatural selection of
species of the genus Homo with particular
reference to their brains.
I added the smiley face narrowing the
range of adult behavior open to him may
be protracted.
corticogenesis evolved in Homo only
around zero five ma during the middle
plisocene in adolescents.
Nowadays, co activity between prefrontal
and caudal cortices underlies agile
working memory.
From the perspective of the fep, these
differences near anatomical testified to
structural priors probably established
through neuro epigenetic evolution, which
contextualize experience dependent
learning and planning is inference at a
somatic timescale.
It's relevant that the interplay between
working memory load and associate
reinforcement learning aspects prediction
errors via front parietal and dopa
energetic striational neuronal circuits
involving algorithmic like effects
mediated by loops with basal ganglia with
likely impingement also of episodic and
procedural long term memory input
remedial temporal hippocampal
cortisones.
You can read the middle section.
When considering early Pleistocene
behavior, we need not assume that
relationships between different kinds of
memory of memory were less complex
psychocognitively than ours.
It is prosaically sufficient to infer
that they were simply less frequent owing
to earlier consolidation of cerebral
networks in Homo erectus smaller brain.
That's being restated, we already talked
about it earlier in our introduction.
Daniel: Yes, it reflects many of the so
called biological attributes that
archaeologists study in terms of cranial
volume and developmental trajectories,
and reaches towards some of those more
ineffable or at least unrecorded
cognitive phenotypes like working memory,
ability to integrate diverse stimuli and
so on.
More on that.
Homo erectus observers brains may have
lacked neuronal networks efficient enough
for enabling them to develop innovative
behavioral responses in the early
Pleistocene that were habit forming a
zone of bounded surprise here and after
Zbs restricted them.
Possibly, observations by early Homo
erectus were translated often into
activity intermediate between emulation
and imitation, owing to limited foresight
about the significance of precise
manipulations for determining the
practicality and effectiveness of an
outcome dimly envisaged, their ZVS
limited their ability to join up the
mental steps involved in planning and to
infer counterfactual possibilities.
That is a fundamental aspect of active
inference that selection of actions and
plans is based on minimizing the free
energy to be anticipated in undertaking
them.
Minimizing effort.
And also extremely interestingly, as we
explored in Live Stream 52 with Lancelot
Costa, free energy is not the only
discrepancy measure, and one that was
mentioned was the Earth mover's
distance.
So it's interesting to think about active
inference with the Earth mover's distance
if you are actually moving earth zones
abounded surprisal ZVS are different from
the zones of latent solutions ZLS
proposed by Tenney et al.
In 2009 in their attempt to explain the
lack of cumulative culture in great apes
on the basis that cultural complexity is
restricted by the limited potentials for
individual intervention zones abounded
surprisal are separated by varying
degrees of surprisal from the
species'prototypical behavioral
repertoire and could therefore resist the
gravitational pull of the ZLS.
The focus of the zbs concept is on the
observers and their ability to make sense
of an observed innovation encoding and
subsequent copying of an innovation
depends on the degree of disparity or
surprisal between predictable behavior
which are those typical of the species
and the perceptual incoming information
about novel behaviors.
The ZVS allows any potentially novel or
unorthodox behavior to be copied provided
that the ranges or levels of surprisal
provoked in observers are tolerated or
manageable by them.
The ZPs is constrained by the capacity of
a species'cerebral neuronal network as
opposed to potentially a sociocultural
explanation which might argue that the
continuity or pattern overall of a tool's
appearance would be rather constrained by
the capacity of a social group's
transmission capacity.
It's a yes and they're proposing a
different tack.
Zbs focuses on the observer of an
innovation and hence ZLS and Zbs can be
useful complementary concepts.
I think we checked but we never went
below min two in this paper properties of
mirror neuron circuitry are necessary
prerequisites for imitative copying the
left side of our brain contains neurons
with canonical properties involved in
tool use and perhaps understanding it.
The matter of understanding raises
unavoidable awkward epistemological
problems of neurology.
However, mirology is about parts and
holes.
Dean: The cardinal and the ordinal okay
chimpanzees resemble macaques and they
differ from them in sharing what with
humans coincidental prefrontal
somatotopic responses to transitive
behavior intransitive observation humans
differ from both in that arcuit I was
trying to practice this before we came on
live and I still trip.
Sorry.
Arcuit faciculous white matter has
undergone evolutionary modification
affecting temporal low connectivity.
Learnt behavior involves long term
working memory and procedural memory.
Conscious modification of learned
behavioral patterns reasonably permits
distinguishing long term working memory
from short term attention.
Working memories even though most long
term memory is implicit implicit and non
declarative the boundary between explicit
and implicit memory is porous.
It's a broken line.
Skillful acts imply fact for
propositional perception.
Individual train sequences changed to a
greater extent earlier in learning and
stabilized later.
Patterns of neuronal activity became
increasingly distinct for trained
sequences carried out at full speed the
selective importance of particular
neuronal groups and included striatal
activation.
Comparing the motor sequences and carried
out at different speeds permitted an
analysis of the observation that areas of
motor and sensory motor cortices show
relatively slight changes in patterns of
neuronal activity that are specific for
particular sequences following training
plausibly on account of the slow speed at
which participants previously been paced
during training.
Hence, defining that patterns of sequence
specific activation are strongest when
performing at greatest speed implies that
investigating fine grained patterns of
activity requires participants to cope
with a strong manual challenge.
Activation is bilateral because
fashioning stone requires precise and
accurate monitoring in an organized
forward sequence of perception action
with feedback homo erectus brains had an
appropriate working memory.
Moreover, they had to have had a
hierarchically organized neurocognitive
capacity to generate in an observer the
combinatorial ability needed for there to
be any acceptably accurate copying.
The Stone undergoing artifactual
modification as envisaged outcome that is
abstracted and understood implicitly by
both parties, albeit invisible explicitly
during the materializing through shaping
process.
Such abstraction severely challenges
innate homeostatic drives in naive
observers.
Daniel: Rebro neuroimaging of students
learning to nap chopping tools via v
those learning to nap BF Lcts suggests
significant distinctions in their
respective judgments concerning the
physical accuracy of predicted outcomes
versus strategical appropriateness in
preparing the attended tool.
It is as if the two groups were trying
out different cognitive strategies
differently during their respective
apprenticeships.
Accurately repeated preparations of
Bflcts evolved hand in hand with
preferential natural selection of a
propensity for developments in haptic
working memory.
It must not be forgotten, of course, that
working memory can also be an external
physical resource hashtag stigmaji that
facilitates copying e g handbooks of
instructions, YouTube demonstrations or
physical models available for copying e g
models in an artist studio or stone
artifacts visible to paleolithic
observers.
As argued elsewhere, working memory is a
complex multidimensional concept.
You can take the last part.
Dean: Evolution by natural selection is
inherently conservative and emergent
neural representations exploited by lone
individuals need not have been shared
automatically by other minds and groups
of largely inarticulate home erectus
whose adaptive priors guided their action
perception cycles towards adaptive
unsurprising states by way of minimizing
variation of free energy.
Those priors could involve neuro
epigenetically controlled expressions of
genes implicated in those cerebral
neuronal developments that prioritize
routine expectations and consolidate
habitual behavior to the detriment of
recognizing the epistemic affordances
that underwrite curiosity and surprising
novelty seeking behavior.
In consequence, some infrequently found
technological aspects of early
Pleistocene innovative behavior may well
have been isolated instances until such
times, active inference brought about
modification of adaptive behavior sorry.
Active priors, thereby permitting
acceptance and adoption by observers of
unorthodox behavior that had failed to
provide adaptive advantage.
Hitherto.
Daniel: So much to unpack with what
active inference allows.
Dean: Right?
Daniel: So that is where our discussion
of the key rings of the two papers ends.
Just as a reminder, the more extensive
quotes are great resources to see in the
final versions of the paper and so on.
And in the following couple of slides we
wanted to bring in a few other directions
a sampling of the extra resources that
Dean and I were looking through in our
zero preparation.
And do you have any comments on this
before I describe this side by side?
Dean: Yeah, I think it's good that you
show the two representations on the right
side of the screen.
I think oftentimes we think of things of
interstate as here are the two train
tracks and they are in perfect parallel.
What I also think often happens is the
shortest distance between two points from
formalism aspect is a straight line.
But when what we're talking about is
generative models, we're talking about
two kinds of time one that's continuous
and one that's discrete.
And our ability to uptake something may
be afforded when we meander slightly so
the representation on the left isn't to
remove the idea of the barbell or to
impose on the model that it has to be
direct.
Sometimes getting to the answer comes
about in kind of strange and wonderful
ways.
Sometimes things happen suddenly because
we meander.
So I'll turn over the actual diagram now
to you and be able to talk a little bit
about that in terms of how we shape that
in terms of discrete and continuous
time.
Daniel: Awesome.
Well, this is Figure 4.3 from Par Pazulo
and Friston's 2022 active inference
textbook that we have textbook groups at
the institute around and two different
taxonomic groups, maybe generative
modelus erectus and generative modelus
habilis or something like that, are
juxtaposed in a way that highlights their
structural similarity but also calls
attention to some of their details.
On the top is a partially observable
Markov decision process.
And this is a discrete time
representation of a generative model.
The hidden states are evolving through
time and there's a past, present and
future which are indexed with temporal
markers time minus one, time right now,
time plus one.
And at each time there's the emission of
observables.
That's the tail of two densities.
It can emit generative AI densities from
hidden states or it can dean hidden
states from observables.
That's the A matrix D is the prior b
describes how those hidden states change
through time and G shapes policy
selection through expected free energy
that intervenes in how hidden states
change through time.
And more briefly in the continuous time
generative model rather than explicit
representation of past, present and
future.
The approach taken is much more resonant
with generalized coordinates of motion or
a Taylor series expansion in which all
past, present and future time points are
implicitly predicted through the
specification of the derivatives of
increasingly high order around the target
variable latent state x.
There's a lot more to say.
But when I saw Dean bring in the straight
and the wavy and the kind of meta train
track that together they enabled seeing,
I thought 4.3, that's where we wanted to
be.
Dean: And here's the interesting thing.
Even in that representation, if you were
to suddenly realize that you liked the
relaxing meandering route, that you're
not always in a hurry, you would probably
have a better chance of realizing that in
continuous time the suddenness would
occur as you stretched your window of
analysis out, which again seems
counterintuitive, but that's what the
representation affirms.
Daniel: And one last note on this before
you introduce the next one is in this
Figure 4.3 we see a crystallization of
methodological pluralism in active
inference.
So all questions of the form how does
inference, active inference treat x
phenomena?
Even for a specified subsystem?
There is no a priori reason to favor the
left or the right foot.
We want the barbell loaded on both sides
before we bench press it.
And so even the decision of the time
window and the treatment of time, which
is one of the most absolutely fundamental
decisions in a model, let alone further
structural learning questions which were
mentioned earlier in the quotations.
Even at that most fundamental divergence
between discrete and continuous time
generative models, the active infra Ant
absolutely has a decision.
So what do you see here and what do we
want to bring in?
Dean: Yeah, this was Ryan Smith's paper.
And what I like about this is he broke it
down into decision active inference just
to if you want to go back and have a look
at that live stream set.
What he was trying to speak to there was
that a lot of stuff that's going on in
folk psychology doesn't contradict what
we now kind of understand in terms of how
we can model things out using active
inference.
And again, you can explain the diagram
better than I can, but I think what's
interesting here is to decide to make a
choice to copy or not to copy.
To throw a stone or not to throw a
stone.
There's two slides here that we kind of
have to kind of pull together again for
what I wanted to focus on, which is on
the next slide next.
But here what I want to do is kind of
talk about this paragraph on the bottom
left hand side.
You have a paper about sensory
attenuation.
What do we pay attention to as an outcome
desensitization?
This only becomes problematic when
contingencies in the environment, when
the environment changes over time.
Right.
So we are talking about things that
agents do in time and in place.
But what this paper was talking about was
sort of the folk psychological and some
of those stories that we've used to try
to explain things and focuses on what's
going on in the envelope, what's going on
in the niche.
This highlights an important distinction
between this type of habit formation and
other mechanisms promoting habitlike
patterns of behavior in decision active
inference, for example.
Actions can also become resistant to
change after repeated experience because
agents build up highly confident beliefs
about the reward probabilities under each
action.
If contingencies, change could take a
very large number of trials for agents to
unlearn such beliefs.
So I wanted to throw this in as a
complement to the habitization stuff that
was in the copied or not to copy paper.
Do you want to explain the diagram real
quick?
Daniel: My only comment there is with
respect to Ali's question about copy
discard, the shadow of to copy or not to
copy is to discard or not to discard.
Because if people have been hitting their
rocks one way and somebody else even if
the functional mirror neurons allow one
to understand that one is doing it
differently, there's a whole variety of
things that can happen and not.
All of them involve the successful
contagion of even an resolutely positive
improvement on tool use and especially
with complex trade off frontiers and
partially obscured views and all these
other social complexities.
That is going to mean that to copy or not
to copy to discard or not to discard copy
discard becomes a central piece in
compositional.
Accounts of surprise minimization under
the hierarchically mechanistic minds.
Dean: So on this slide, which was just a
continuation of that live stream set or
deck, I'm going to drop down to the
fourth paragraph.
If the highest value in an outcome space
was specified for observing tasting ice
cream in the policy and the policy space
included, either choose don't move or
choose walk to the ice cream truck and
buy ice cream.
A deciding active agent, active inference
agent will infer that walking to the ice
cream truck and buying ice cream is the
highest probability policy.
That is, it will form the intention to go
buy ice cream.
In addition, when considering the range
of cases involving goal directed choice,
we have been unsuccessful at identifying
examples where the policy would play a
role inconsistent with representing
desired outcomes.
Now, here's an interesting thing.
Even back then, if you look at the ice
cream cone and you ask it to the third
person now, Daniel and Dean looking at
the slide, is the ice cream truck closer
to us as we're viewing this or further
away from us than the actual ice cream
cone is?
You get one sense of it and then if I
grab this line at first it appears that
the ice cream cone truck is closer to
us.
If I do this, however, and I grab this
line just like that, pull that away.
Now all of a sudden, what's in the
foreground?
The ice cream cone.
So oftentimes when we're trying to figure
out what we desire or what our goal is,
we're completely unaware of how we're
setting up our own frame, what rule we're
actually following.
If we have a rule, we're completely
unaware of it.
And yet that has a huge decision
implication on what's the desired
foreground background here?
How are we coming about to this idea that
this one shape which we're going to have
to arrive at by removing things is more
advantageous than just leaving it the way
it is.
So just to have one perspective on
something unidirectional versus to be
able to have those two perspectives on
something.
So again, this was in comparison to a
folk psychology narrative of telling how
we might come to behaving versus the
active inference.
What Ryan wanted to do in his paper was
say they're not fighting with one
another.
And oftentimes, if you actually
understand that you've made a lot of
choices that you're not even aware of,
that your generative model sometimes is a
reduction to some rules that you may or
may not even be able to articulate.
And that's fine.
Yes, it will influence what you do
present as an articulation.
It doesn't change what we now understand
as the mechanisms that are present and
that may help us.
In terms of some of that predictive
process.
Daniel: Awesome live stream 46 way back
when.
All right, just a few more pieces to
bring into the puzzle.
So I'll give the first description on
each of them and then Dean, feel free to
kind of bring in why you wanted these to
be here.
So here's a paper, a variational
synthesis of evolutionary and
developmental dynamics which was written
with Friston, myself, Constance Knight,
Par and Campbell.
We recently uploaded it to archive and
one of the main novelties or
contributions of this paper was in
contrast with previous multiscale
biologically oriented active inference or
fep models which used the formalism of
nested POMDPs to model nested Markov
blankets, thus creating one bigger and
bigger tree with finer and finer leaves.
We used an explicit, discontinuous,
multiscale or scale friendly jump such
that within the lifetime, the intra
generational action perception loops and
also developmental loops that we heard
about in some selections from the papers
today that that particular partition that
thing, over the course of its life in an
ecologically embodied way can have bottom
up causation to this higher order thing,
which is a population thing.
And this higher order extended genotypic
thing also uses the exact same particular
partition mathematics and framing that we
see across systems in active.
And another way to look at that is here
in the center is one thing with a blue
ring going around it at a given level and
it is itself composed of these smaller
things which also are composed of even
smaller things.
And also that main blue ring is playing a
role in potentially a larger thing.
And this is the scale friendliness or the
scale freeness of the fep formalism
discussed in an ontogenetic phylogenetic
setting within and amongst generations.
And rather than utilizing this graphed
bigger and bigger POMDPs strategy, we
introduce an explicit discontinuity in
that things at a lower level are sampled
or instantiated from a higher level
distributional thing and the differential
success of those within generation
trajectories can result in bottom up
causation modifying the extended
genotypic thing.
I hope that we'll have more sessions to
talk more about this paper and related
work, but just wanted to give that quick
overview.
Dean: And I don't have a lot of deep
background in biology, so the reason why
I was hoping that you would be interested
in at least touching on this is because I
think, again, we're back to so which have
we chosen to do?
Have we chosen to zoom in on the scale
friendly or have we zoom in on the scale
friendly or zoom out onto the scale
free?
And I think we get a better understanding
when we're able to appreciate the
differences and put them back together in
sort of our own model.
Daniel: Great.
On to the next.
Here is a paper with Sean O'Connor who
led this effort and myself from the end
of 2022 predictive Processing
interpretation of the Mirror test and
implications of a reflection prediction
for human cognition.
And just to read one sentence from the
abstract, we hypothesize that a
reflection prediction upon which our
predictive processing interpretation of
the mirror test is built may also offer a
novel perspective to understand how
humans locate themselves relative to a
mirror, imitate others and are self aware
from a social perspective.
So what have you seen in that mirror
mirror on the screen?
And why did you want it here?
Dean: Because I think the sensory first
of all, I strongly recommend people get
this paper and read it because I thought
it was an excellent paper and it should
become on part of more people's reading
lists.
One of the things that really speaks to
very clearly and makes a strong case
around is the role of sensory attention
and bringing the concept of sensory
attenuation into the world of predictive
processing.
And I think it would be something that
would be helpful for people to
understand, especially if you're thinking
that, for example and I don't forget,
Danny, you'll know what this is.
But one of the things that was talked
about in this paper was the idea that if
you believe you do not have a limb, then
one of the things that you could do is
come up with a way of a mirror showing
you without that limb, even if you
already possessed it.
So it's reinforcing what Hector and
Michael Andy Clark were talking about in
terms of so how does active inference
help us get to maybe some more plausible
answers in prosaic ways?
And so the sensory attenuation piece to
me was really valuable and tied in with
some of the concepts we're talking about
here.
Daniel: Yeah, one thought on that is
let's grant an effective mirror neuron or
recognition capacity, just spatially in
terms of tool usage.
So that is not always granted with
eyesight and partial occlusion of the
working locations of tools and all of
this.
But let's just say that an observer can
observe somebody else doing a motor
behavior and entirely understands the
basis of that motor behavior like the
person does a pirouette or they write a
line incursive or they play violin.
You can have absolute understanding of
the mechanisms of the baseball pitcher,
of the hockey stick.
Yet there are multiple reasons from an
embodied and cognitive perspective why
the behavior cannot be copied.
We can all understand that there are
certain sport acts that are not just
strength limited and they're not even
necessarily dexterity limited that we
cannot do.
We cannot write in a language we do not
know by hand, even though we might have
the motor dexterity.
And so that's a semantic explanation or
quite simply and to call back the zone of
bounded surprisal an observer may observe
a hetero praxis, a different praxis and
simply, implicitly or even explicitly
believe that's unlikely for me to do.
And as it was thought, so it shall be
done.
The innovation is over and then lastly
and a little bit most Extrapolatively
previously in some work I've juxtaposed
Buckminster Fuller's life and work in
times with that of William Blake.
And the prompting quote from the paper
was above zones of bounded surprisal are
different from the zones of latent
solution in their attempt to explain the
lack of cumulative culture in great apes
on the basis that cultural complexity is
restricted by the limited potentials for
individual invention.
So Bucky and Blake were both tremendously
inventive individuals and to reflect a
few lines of some Blake poetry the
auguries of Innocence begins with to see
a world in a grain of sand and a heaven
in a wild flower hold infinity in the
palm of your hand and eternity in an
hour.
Those are some of the famous opening
lines of that poem and they speak to this
time representation but the closing lines
are less often quoted.
We are led to believe a lie when we see
not through the eye which was born in a
night to perish in a night when the soul
slept in beams of light.
God appears and God is light to those
poor souls who dwell in night.
But does a human form display to those
who dwell in realms of day?
And I'll let you get the word on that.
Dean: Well, here's the thing.
I want to thank again the authors who are
going to be joining us for the one and
two for allowing us to pull two of their
papers into proximity and allow us to
talk about them so proximally because we
I think I speak for both of us, but you
can correct me on this, Daniel.
I think with the use of active inference
and our continuous updating with active
inference as a way of strategizing are
coming to realize that sometimes things
that seem really distal and unrelated
when brought together, you as the person
who is looking at two things at once with
both of your eyes open tend to learn a
lot.
And so whether it's pulling Buckminster
Fuller and Blake into the same slide deck
or talking about to copy or not to copy
and snakes and ladders it's actually a
real treat to be able to bring things
that seem like well, conventionally.
That was field work and this is lab
work.
Being able to have 1ft in both of those
realms really helps the person who likes
to go back and forth who is moving from a
position of being really familiar with
the subject matter to being somebody who
can actually get into the predictive
matters because they're more comfortable
in doing the update thing.
They're not quite so stuck and bound.
And that means when I see ZLS and ZVS
beside one another makes me very, very
happy.
So that's why I wanted you to get
acknowledged for some of the work that
you've done in terms of this isn't the
first time that you seen an advantage in
bringing two things that don't seem like
they belong on the same table and
bringing them together and kind of going,
whoa, look what happens when you do.
Daniel: Great.
Thanks.
Any final comments or I'll give a final
thought.
Dean: Go for it.
Daniel: All right, well, I would just
like to echo your words.
We really appreciated, even, dare I say,
working with the authors in this zero and
even negative dot one, the first of its
kind interval.
These papers initially, to me at least,
felt like two pillowy beds of plain
text.
Can't think of any other way to say it
right now.
However, once we dug at that field site
and we brushed off some of those uni and
bifacial tools and ideas, there was just
more and more to find and explore.
So I'm very much looking forward to the
coming one, two, and potentially beyond.
And we hope you've enjoyed this.
53.0.
Dean: Thanks, Daniel.
Daniel: All right.
Thank you.
Dean: Dean.
Daniel: Farewell.